new york city spent 1.7 million dollars
to build a public bathroom i'm not
kidding
literally 24 sycamores park comfort
station reconstruction you cannot make
this up if you look at this the project
timeline was that in october 2014 new
york city started to build a public
bathroom they haven't finished it all
the way until august of 2021. for those
of you keeping track at home it's almost
seven years how much did it cost 1.7
million dollars paid for by the city
council that literally looks like a lego
building that i could have built in a
summer with my bare hands but that right
there cost 1.7 million dollars and took
seven years to build what is going on
what i mean
hey you two over there giggling what's
going on i don't know how does that cost
1.7 million dollars is each brick a
grand we are in the wrong business
yo new york de blasio eric adams whoever
is in charge now you need a bathroom
bill call the bomb boys i'll do it for
1.5 million
you get a 200k discount
and we want a trophy for saving taxpayer
money
[Laughter]
what is going on here now of course john
running the best business or research
team this morning went deep into the
internet they say you know what how is
it that american governments local
governments etc spent 1.7 million
dollars to build literally what looks
like an outhouse in the playground in
new york city i wonder what they do
around the rest of the world and so what
we found is a chinese construction
company built a 57-floor skyscraper in
19 working days in central china that's
what the chinese built 19 days and go
back and show what it took us seven
years to build what is going on that
took seven years for us to build and
then if you go and look at china they
built this [ __ ] in 19 working days
what is going on in this world it's
clown world broad sustainable building a
construction company spent four and a
half months fabricating the buildings
building's
2736 modules before construction began
and this thing in china now what is the
quote it's like abraham lincoln said you
know if i had four hours to cut down a
tree i'd spend the first three
sharpening the axe that's what the
chinese do they playing around they said
we got 19 days let's go even if you
include the four and a half months of
actually putting it together it took
them five months to build this thing
america we still were trying to figure
out where we're gonna source the bricks
to overpay for now if you continue to
think about this there is a obvious very
very very big difference there is a
centrally controlled authoritarian
totalitarian government that's running a
lot of stuff over there and here we have
much more of a democratic free process
obviously we believe that the democratic
free process is much better but when you
start to look at absurd things like a
1.7 million dollar bathroom being built
on a playground in new york city you
have to start asking yourself where is
all the taxpayer money going what are
they doing with it why is it that it
took seven years to build this and it is
obviously so egregiously expensive well
my friends that's bureaucracy sometimes
maybe what we should do is we should
start to figure out how to be more
efficient more effective and also save
money and be better capital allocators
that's why career politicians may not be
the best people
to actually run a lot of these
organizations and maybe we should get
people who have experience actually
allocating capital in positions of power
and influence in order to allocate
capital experience may matter john what
do you think about our friends building
a 1.7 million dollar bathroom i mean
five years for design until construction
is a little bit egregious i'll call it
two years to actually build the bathroom
itself is ridiculous you should have got
that done in three months i could have
drawn the blueprint for that building on
the back of a napkin
that's that's the truth that thing is
small as hell someone people in the
comments are saying they could be they
could have built that thing in a weekend
literally that's what they're saying
they're saying i've done construction
projects that cost 90 less and i would
have built it in a weekend
i mean i mean it's crazy yeah and it
just speaks to government spending right
the total disregard for taxpayer money
uh and everyone should be pissed about
it because quite frankly it's it's abuse
of power right it's people that
understand there's gonna be no
repercussions for their actions people
that are willing to funnel money to
other organizations for companies that
are supporting this and all the other
things and i think it's uh it's it's
disgusting really is what it is
the other thing that i i think goes uh
goes unnoticed here is uh it takes so
long that it actually when did uh de
blasio come in to um uh come into office
was he even there when uh when they
started this in 2014 i don't know how
long he's been in office but like you
now start to have construction projects
2014. okay so he came in in 2014. so
literally uh you have construction
progress uh projects that are spanning
multiple administrations and so like you
can't even just lay blame to like one
administration right it's not like oh
that one is incompetent but the next
one's gonna be great right it's
literally it's a system and this is why
i believe and people get real mad when i
say this but i believe a lot of these
systems
especially at the lower level
a leader can only do so much within the
system right so if you look at some of
these places like mayors for example
there's a lot of mayors around the
country they have no power for the most
part their city council which by the way
the city council paid for this
and so what you end up getting is you
end up getting these really weird
situations where if you don't have the
power to actually be a leader and say
hey i'm gonna drive this project to
finality i'm gonna drive it from a cost
effectiveness standpoint then what
you're doing is you're actually managing
by bureaucracy just because you have the
city council doing it yeah and so now
all of a sudden let's say that you have
a city council full of seven 10 12 15
people depending on how big your
population is
if you have two superstars and everyone
else is average
well they pull the superstars down and
you have an average city council the
odds that you're gonna get seven ten
fifteen of them is is not there and so
again it goes back to it's like having
an executive team that's making
decisions inside of a business and all
of the executives are like man the ceo
and the cfo are amazing but everybody
else is average and guess what the ceo
and cfo don't have unilateral decision
making power they have to basically get
the consensus of everyone to operate
yeah it's just bad so i just i i joke
about it i think it's ridiculous but i
do think that there's a system that
actually has a big impact on this is not
just the individuals
but again i would love to know what
construction company convinced
new york city to pay a 1.7 million
dollars to build that bathroom yeah and
because i want equity in that company
because that's not the only one they did
it with
i'm sure they're doing it to a bunch of
states they're probably the same
construction company that literally
spent 17 years doing the construction on
laguardia airport
because i think they're still working on
it it's beautiful it's amazing but
literally there are people getting paid
i think that there was 17 union breaks a
day going on at laguardia because they
literally been working on that for a
decade
it's crazy
what john it's a big project
why are you trying to be defend these
people i'm not getting the kickback
i think there's no better customer than
uncle sam
spence spends money doesn't look at the
bill just signs away oh you invoice for
sure
i think there's no better customer than
uncle sam yeah but also to your point i
don't think it's necessarily the
individuals right because uh we'd
probably be mistaken to think that mayor
de blasio is going through and looking
through all these different charges and
these construction projects like there's
people in charge of these things that
are that are determining these decisions
and to your point maybe it's one
individual maybe it's a group of 10
individuals and there's some kind of
bureaucracy that's created through that
but ultimately this is happening all
throughout the country it's not just new
york it's not just mayor de blasio it's
not just one individual that you can
point to it's the total system right and
it lets things like this go and this is
just one example i'm sure there's
smaller ones i'm sure there's bigger
ones but this is one ridiculous example
that you can point to and just say that
government spending is out of control
right people are paying more taxes every
single year every single year they're
the people the tax amount that they
collect goes up and up and up and seeing
these projects should piss people off
because it's just clear that they are
doing things with your money that are
not uh that are not smart right that
decisions that you would not make with
your own capital that private companies
would not be able to do and turn a
profit so ultimately i think those are
the things that people need to look at
and say how can we change the system not
necessarily the people but the system
that is enabling this to happen